росія про та заповнюю договір про зону
вільно та торги до лісу україну з великому
2016 руку президент України
Петра Порошенка дізнався ще економіка
україни знаючи через те значних надлишок
1 київ готовий дати слово за раді цитата
свободи та на закладеності за дикі ледве
ще небесних мід Росії
тату з косово не зони вільного цькування
експорт сходить на 1 мільярд доларів
США близько 2 сотки в завального
експорт україни до тіла ВНЗ вид росія
також внесла україну до спуску українців
про те як з прямого на продуктовий
обірву український прем'єр арсеній яценюк
заявив муразі введення ембарго Росія
вранці від дзеркальної вигляд по адже експерти
у давно не чоппера орієнтація в біг
європейському ринку коли Україна на
кістка україна продовжує
переорієнтувалися на еньші ринку я
думаю що правильний шлях там ще росії
ніколи не було передач іван їм
партнером на врятувати на брейку сторгували
не воїни та вино сцен з русі іван iii
був і економіки повернуто з Росії
дощок сильно політизований і за словами
експортерів загинуло було і вивернув нас
грузія та й цим уроки в 2008 2008
уроку росія закрила свій ринок для
грузії та c20 великий удар для економіки
грузії
але якщо проведення активних
структурних реформ грузії в принципі
змогла замінити його сильно ямщик roi
нативних структурних реформ крим пафф
відриваючи су пара москви і до і я вас
приводу так дзвінок прибирання януковича і
дати цифру 3 мільярди доларів
віці росія в грудні 2013 року видала Україні
за президентства віктора януковича
москва видно вилазь образ
реструктуризації баргону в умовах його
там і україна ви вирішила в загартовані
виплачувати та сайборг росія збирається
під відійду суду формального нас може
відразу б ти вже 30 великого брешу дня за
словом експерти в російсько-українську
економічні видно снс і але
поляризовані
the moon якщо точок у готелях загиблими
найбільшою годиною